[Musik]
der lauf der geschichte führt manchmal
schon zu ziemlich kuriosen ergebnissen
und heute stellen wir dir eine der wohl
größten historische kuriosität
bevorratet er je untergekommen sein
dürfte einer mit russischen militär
vollgestopfte exklave die die ein
stachel 400 kilometer weit vom
russischen mutterland tief in eu und
nato territorium steckt ja dieses kleine
stück russland namens kaliningrad ist
nicht nur von allen seiten von ländern
umgeben die mitglied der eu sein sondern
auch der nato es ist quasi ein
hochgerüstetes trojanisches pferd putins
mitten in europa meine lieben freunde
wir sprechen von einem ort mit einer
knappen million einwohnern dessen
einzige bestimmung massive
militärpräsenz so nah wie möglich am
herzen europas ist deine wirtschaftlich
ist kaliningrad völlig unbedeutend im
vergleichsportal verarmt das bip der
region liegt unter fünf milliarden euro
das ist weniger als das bip von zum
beispiel vorteile
ja und genau wie pforzheim wurde dieser
ort in krieg weitgehend zerstört und
dann nach 1945 tatort zahlreiche
architektur verbrechen das alte
königsberger schloss wurde zum beispiel
durch dieses schmankerl des sozialismus
ersetzt etwas für echte liebhaber und
dabei war er seit 340 eine der schönsten
und bedeutendsten handelsstädte europas
stolze königliche residenz und
hauptstadt preußens ein epizentrum von
kunst und kultur
hier wurden unzählige bedeutende
persönlichkeiten geworden der
schriftsteller eta hoffmann die
künstlerin käthe kollwitz die
mathematiker david hilbert und christian
goldbach chemie nobelpreisträger otto
wallach der physiker gustav robert
kirchhoff der philosoph immanuel kant
und viele viele andere aber all das ist
vergangenheit kaliningrad ist heute
nichts als ein riesiger
militärstützpunkt wirtschaftlich und
kulturell praktisch unbedeutend wie und
bedeutet null obwohl es sich tief
innerhalb des territoriums der eu
befindet wäre kaliningrad wenn es ein
unabhängiges land wäre ärmer als büro
oder sogar kabul
damit du dir eine vorstellung von der
kasse nahm dort machen kannst erreichen
die kaliningrad gerade mal ein drittel
dessen was ein pole
gleich nebenan erwirtschaftet und eine
großteil der wirtschaft hängt sowieso
auf gedeih und verderb direkt von den
dort stationierten russischen streik
wie du dir vorstellen kannst stand diese
enklave zu zeiten des kalten krieges und
des warschauer paktes unter sowjetischer
verwaltung das stellte damals kannten
bleiben denn alle nachbarländer waren ja
auch teil der udssr ohne ins warschauer
pakts heute liegen die dinge jedoch ganz
anders
kaliningrad ist für seine nachbarländer
zu einer herausforderung geworden zu
einer politischen und vor allem zu einer
militärischen herausforderungen und hier
fängt unsere geschichte an so richtig
spannend zu werden
das ist also gut auf den wir möchten
mehr über diesen wenig bekannten und
durchaus erstaunlichen ort erzählen
bist du bereit dann lasst uns loslegen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
liebe freunde von visual basic und zu
verstehen was kaliningrad heute ist
können wir jetzt eine geschichte nicht
ignorieren bevor sie also nach
kaliningrad gehen müssen wir uns ein
wenig über preußen die deutsche
geschichte und auch die sowjetunion
unterhalten das gebiet des heutigen
kaliningrad war bis 1945 teil des
deutschen reichs im jahr 1255 wurde dort
während des kreuzzugs eroberungen
christianisierung russischen gebiet von
den ritter des deutschen ordens die
stadt königsberg gegründet von diesem
moment an florierte königsberg als eine
wichtige handelns klar
sie gehörte zur hanse und war 300 jahre
lang die hauptstadt preußens posten
wiederum war 1815 gründungsstaat des
deutschen bundes und gehörte ab 1871 zum
neugegründeten deutschen reich
so weit so gut allerdings nahm die
geschichte könig bergs nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg einen klitzekleinen wendepunkt
am ende des kriegs wurden dort sehr
harte kämpfe ausgetragen es kam es zur
totalen zerstörung der stadt und der
gefangennahme von fast 100.000 deutsche
soldaten durch die rote armee dann nach
kriegsende annektierte die sowjetunion
das ganze königsberger gebiet und machte
es zum bestandteil der russischen
republik gerissen warum nun stalin
wollte unbedingt einen strategischen
hafen der auch im winter eisfrei war die
sorge es löschen in am königsberg aus
und adaptierten zu ehren des
bolschewistischen revolution erst kein
kalli den ortsnamen der heute kennen
kaliningrad und sichere du dir denken
was dann nach der russischen aktion
geschah
die in kaliningrad gebiet noch übrig
gebliebenen deutschen wurden zwischen
1947 48 gewaltsam vertrieben und das
gebiet wurde mit sowjetischen familien
kolonisiert diese stammten aus dem krieg
zerstörten gebieten oder wagen einfach
angehörige der dort von nun an
stationierten sowjetischen soldaten und
gesprächen jeder von sehr sehr vielen
soldaten
tja josef stalin war noch mal nicht
dafür bekannt zu kleckern umso mehr aber
dafür ordentlich zu lassen
der punkt ist dass kaliningrad auf diese
weise im grunde zu dem wurde was es
heute ist ein riesiger amphibische
militärstützpunkt zu wasser zu luft und
zu lande so und nun kommt der zur ersten
großen historischen kuriosität die
strategische bedeutung des eisfreien
hafen zwar für die vw jetzt ja schon
sagen aber kurioserweise nachdem diese
erst mit dem ende der sowjet ära und dem
zerfall des ostblocks so richtig zu denn
seitdem wurde kaliningrad zu einer
russischen hochburg im herzen der nato
und mittlerweile zu einem schmerzhaften
stachel im fleisch des nordatlantischen
bündnisses und du fragst dich die so
kaliningrad für die natur so gefährlich
ist nun hatte ich jetzt mal gut west
eine russische armee in der eu
dass die folgende zahlen mal auf der
zunge zergehen was 20.000 fest
stationierte soldaten und 58
marineeinheiten zerstörer fregatten
raketen u-boote torpedo brutto und
angriffsschiffe mehr als 800 kanzler und
1.200 eur 345 8 in der rechtssysteme mit
einem kaliber von über 100 mm und fast
200 flugzeuge und hubschrauber und liebe
freunde dies sind nur einige details
welche über den derzeitigen stand der
stadtsanierung große streitkräfte in
dieser gewaltigen militärbasis bekannt
sind
[Applaus]
wenn muss bedenken dass der tatsächliche
truppen stand viel höher liegen könnte
warum nun nach dem europa dann in der
ukraine oder alex yoong der krim
eskalierten die spannungen zwischen
europa und russland und dies führte 2014
zur rasanten aufstockung von
streitkräften und waffensystemen diese
aufrüstung hätte es heute an und
hinterlässt eine breite schlagzeilen
spur in den nachrichten trump bestätigt
dass mehr us-truppen nach polen in
sandberg die präsenz der us truppen in
polen wird sich um 1000 soldaten erhöhen
zusätzlich zu den 4500 soldaten die
bereits durch das land portiert dieses
kontingent könnte durch die verlegung
der derzeit in deutschland stationierten
und bald abziehen den amerikanischen
soldaten weiter ausgebaut werden
russland bildet neue divisionen setzt
mehr schiffe und flugzeuge in
kaliningrad gebiet ein
us panzer und truppen auf den weg nach
litauen zu einem längeren einsatz
tja wie du sicherlich schon gemerkt hast
befinden sich die diplomatischen
beziehungen zwischen dem westen und
russland an einem historischen tiefpunkt
beachtenswert ist jedoch insbesondere
diese schwarzen großen an stationiert
nur bestückte iskander raketen in
kaliningrad freunde zusätzlich zu der
langen liste von truppen die wir bereits
erwähnt haben hat putin die creme de la
creme seiner gefährlichsten
waffensysteme nach kaliningrad ein sand
das ist genau die art von waffen die man
nur dann stationierte wenn man das nie
wieder drohungen auch so etwas wie der
krieg steht direkt vor eurer tür
eskalieren möchte das heißt auf ein
bedrohungs demo das uns in die zeiten
des kalten krieges zurück versetzt wir
sprechen hier vor allem über die ist
country gaben die über
boden-boden-raketen verfügung
nuklearsprengköpfe mit einer variablen
sprengt leistung von 5 bis 200 kilo
tragen können und hat sich jetzt gut
fest wenn ein einziges ist kann der
abschluss system ist in der lage mit 32
solcher geschosse in einer einzigen zahl
wird gleichzeitig anzugreifen
diese raketen haben je nach variante
eine reichweite zwischen 380 und 500 km
die iskandar zum beispiel kommt bis zu
500 kilometer weit wodurch die praktisch
jede position in polen lettland oder
litauen angreifen könnte und dazu
gehören natürlich auch die nato
militärstützpunkte in diesem gebiet aber
was ist denn darüber hinaus ist dieses
raketensystem mobil und befindet sich
auf einer art lastwagen wodurch man
seinen standort schnell und bequem
wechseln kann und mit leichtigkeit
unentdeckt bleibt pooth ist natürlich
einwenden kommen schon mag wir alle
wissen dass die hemmschwelle für den
einsatz von atomwaffen sehr hoch ist
soweit wurde punkt jedoch nie gehen nun
darauf kann ich dir nur folgendes
antworten zum einen ist die hemmschwelle
zum einsatz von taktischen präzisions
nukes schon hier niedriger als bei den
großen strategischen bomben welche ganze
städte ausradieren würden denn beim
einsatz der ist kann da würde ja nur ein
stützpunkt oder eine armee vernichtet
werden und zum anderen geht eine ganz
andere gefahr gar nicht von dem ist kann
dann auch sondern von konventionellen
raketen kaliningrad ist nämlich auch
eine gigantische luftwaffenbasis denn
wenn sich die russische militär
industrie in den letzten jahren durch
irgendetwas hervorgetan hat dann vor
allem durch jahrhundert flugsystem ein
hochmodernes look auf der system dass
russland in die ganze welt exportieren
wir sprechen von einem system das in der
lage ist jedes feindliche
flugzeug und umkreis von 250 kilometern
abzuschießen und das bedeutet dass
russland den durchflug von
nato-flugzeugen zwischen westeuropa und
den baltischen staaten von seinem
stützpunkt in kaliningrad aus
kontrollieren könnte
und das bedeutet dass russland technisch
den durchflug von nato-flugzeugen
zwischen westeuropa und den baltischen
staaten und seine stützpunkt in
kaliningrad jederzeit kontrollieren kann
und nun kommen wir zu einem sehr
wichtigen thema denn tatsache ist dass
dieses gesamtes system der land- see-
und luft richtung dass sowohl offensive
als auch defensive ausrüstung kombiniert
eine militärische strategie namens lte
darstellt diese strategie oder
militärische fähigkeit deren akronym and
access area den euro bedeutet besteht
darin gegnerischen einheiten zu lande zu
wasser und in der luft jeglichen zugang
und bewegungsfreiheit in einem
ausgewählten operationsgebiet mit
militärischen mitteln zu versagen
und im grunde millimeter genau zu
kontrollieren
sicherlich kannst du dir vorstellen dass
eine solche fähigkeit russlands mitten
in europa den nato mitgliedern
insbesondere den osteuropäischen
mitgliedern ganz schön große sorgen
bereitet und dies ist einer der
wichtigsten gründe dafür dass die
politischen beziehungen zu russland so
angespannt sind wie seit dem kalten
krieg nicht wert das vertrauen ist so
gering dass die polnische armee sechs
beobachtungstürme entlang der grenze zu
kanada errichtet hat und zwar mit
mitteln der europäischen union
jeder dieser türme ist einfach 50 meter
hoch und mit überwachungs und
verfolgungs ausrüstung ausgestattet um
die russischen bewegungen in lang der
200 kilometer lange grenze zu überwachen
aber moment mal jetzt kommt eine
überraschung denn wenn wir die
militärischen spannungen beiseitelassen
finden wir auf der zivil ebene auf der
ebene der normalen menschen eine ganz
anderes bild
seit dem zerfall der sowjetunion ist der
grenzverkehr zwischen kaliningrad und
der polnischen stadt danzig immer weiter
gestiegen mehr als sechs millionen
menschen polen und russen aus
kaliningrad überquerten dieses jahr die
grenze von spannungen nach der grinten
version ist schließlich handelt es sich
in zwei große städte die keine zwei
autostunden von einander entfernt sind
so dass es üblich war dass die russische
bevölkerung danzig reiste und produkte
zu kaufen die in kaliningrad nicht
erhältlich und ganz natürlich wird ein
wert umfangreiche und kontinuierlicher
austausch von menschen und waren
zwischen eine territorien und einem
anderen am ende auch immer zu
kulturellen und gesellschaftlichen
austausch einem austausch der winterlich
und genau das erklärt warum gerade die
menschen aus dem kaliningrad gebiet in
russland zu jenen zählen die am
wenigsten pro putin sind und am
stärksten europa zugewandt sehen wir uns
das mal etwas genauer an koexistenz
trotz allem lieber als erwähnt ist
kaliningrad trotz aller widrigkeiten
sehr europäisch geprägt das ist
internationaler ausgerichtet
aufgeschlossener als das was für das
russische mutterland typisch ist das
kriegst du aus einer ganz klaren
tatsache ablesen denn im schnitt
verfügen nur 30 prozent der russen über
einen reisepass die meisten waren also
noch nie im ausland aber wenn wir nur
die bürger der oblast kaliningrad
betrachten streckte anteil der reisepass
besitzer plötzlich auf über 70 prozent
der seit ende der 190er ist der
reiseverkehr zwischen den leningrader
gebiet unseren nachbarn in der
europäischen union polen und litauen
stetig am steigen
ein reiseverkehr daneben den tourismus
auch viel mit einkaufen zu tun hat wenn
es eine sache gibt die das kaliningrad
gebiet außer der riesigen militärpräsenz
auszeichnet dann ist es der mangel an
sinnvolle tätigkeiten und interessanten
produkten eine situation die sich 2014
noch weiter verschärft als präsident
putin als reaktion auf die sanktionen
gegen damaskus in der ukraine gegen
russland verhängt wurden den verkauf
einer insel westliche hauptsächlich
europäischer und amerikanischer
lebensmittel und andere produkte
verboten und du kannst es sich ja
vorstellen dass dieser boykott dieses
verbot zu einer drastischen verringerung
der vielfalt und qualität der in
russischen supermärkten erhältlichen
waren geführt hat so begannen die bürger
des kaliningrad gebiet 20 gegenüber
anderen großen eben geografisch
privilegiert sind noch öfter in die
europäischen nachbarländer zu reisen und
saßen um parmesan camembert und
parmaschinken zu kaufen in ausland
einzukaufen wurde zum liebsten hobby der
car linien gerade
[Musik]
und das ist trockener als auf den ersten
blick erscheinen mag denn dank all
dieser reisen hatten die russischen
bürger in kaliningrad sehr engem kontakt
zu den wirtschaftlichen politischen und
sozialen entwicklungen welche die länder
polen und litauen in den letzten jahren
erlebt haben denn dank all dieser reisen
hatten die russischen bürger aus
kaliningrad er engen kontakt zu den
wirtschaftlichen politischen und
sozialen entwicklungen in polen und
litauen in den letzten jahren die kann
ihn gerade haben zb die enorme welle des
wohlstands welche über diese länder in
den letzten jahrzehnten geshoppt ist
hautnah miterleben können
es bedeutet auch dass putins anti europa
vision hier einfach nicht zieht denn
diese vision eines bösen finsteren
feindseligen europas die von den
offiziellen russischen fernsehsender
ankommt passt nicht in europa das die
kalinin gerade erlebt habe ich weiß es
dir nach polen und sehe wie die menschen
mit den russen umgehen alles ist in
ordnung es gibt keine probleme
die polen sind menschen genau wie wir
alexander büroangestellte aus
kaliningrad
hinzu kommt dass entgegen dem was du
jetzt erwarten könnte es die einreise
von ausländern nach kaliningrad durch
die russische regierung immer weiter
erleichtert wurde
[Musik]
tatsächlich war eine der jüngsten
meilensteine in dieser hinsicht die
einführung des kostenlosen
elektronischen visums mitte 2009 ein
visum das nur vier tage vor dem besuch
des territoriums online beantragt werden
musste diese art von wieso ist für
bürger von 43 ländern darunter spanien
deutschland und polen erhältlich und es
gibt zwar keinen zugang für us bürger
aber für nordkoreaner damit irgendeinen
verrückten spleen müssten die russen
halt immer daherkommen in ihrer jetzigen
form scheint die militärischen
spannungen zwischen der nato und
russland in bezug auf kaliningrad für
die normalen menschen dort keine große
bedeutung zu haben
aber tatsache ist dass in ihrer jetzigen
form der militärischen spannungen
zwischen der nato und russland in bezug
auf kaliningrad für die normalen
menschen dort keine große bedeutung zu
haben scheinen und dies ist eine der
vielen gelegenheiten bei denen sich die
spielchen der herrschenden und ihrer
fragwürdigen interessen mit dem
überlagern was in wirklichkeit ein viel
ruhigeres zusammenleben sein kann gut
wie dem auch sei jetzt bist du wer darin
was hältst du davon dass es ein
russisches territorium voller soldaten
raketen kriegsschiffe und atomwaffen im
herzen der eu und der nato gibt und
sollten russland die nato sich mehr um
verständigen bemühen anstatt die
militärische präsenz immer weiter zu
erhöhen und sich gegenseitig
hochzurüsten und nicht zuletzt welche
zukunft sieht er für die region
kaliningrad und die dort lebenden
menschen
ich habe das alles und dann meinung wie
immer in den kommentaren zu diesem video
wir hoffen dass dieses video etwas
gebracht hat was ja geht uns auch einen
daumen hoch und unterstütze uns indem es
mit deinen freunden heißt bei gäste auch
nicht dass wir jede woche neue videos
hochladen also fast keines unserer
updates aber mir unseren kanal und klick
auf das klinge symbol um rechtzeitig
benachrichtigt zu werden macht gut und
bis zum nächsten
[Musik]